اذا دخلت خامس وهدنا في السودان حي
التنفيذ ويسود هدوء انحذر بعد تسجيل
اشتباكات متقطعه وتحليق للطيران في مناطق
بالخرطوم بحري وكان الجيش السوداني وافق
على تمديد الهدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام اضافيه
وجاء في بيان الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش ان
موافقته جاءت لتهدئه الاوضاع وتهيئه
الظروف المناسبه لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف
الجنسيات وتيسير النواحي الانسانيه
للمواطنين السودانيين واعرب الجيش عن امنه
في ان يلتزم من سماهم بالمتمردين لمتطلبات
سريان الهدنه وعدم خرقها
بدورها اعلنت قياده ودعم السريع موافقتها
على مقترح الاليه الثلاثيه واللجنه
الرباعيه بتمديد الهدنه الانسانيه لمده 72
ساعه اضافيه وقالت قياده الدعم السريع
انها تؤكد التزامها التام بشروط الهدنه
الانسانيه واضافت انها تود لفت الانتباه
الى وجود اكثر من مركز لاتخاذ القرار داخل
قاده القوات المسلحه التي وصفتهم
بالانقلابيين وفول النظام البائد اوضحت ان
هذا تسبب في تضارب قراراتهم ما ادى الى
عدم التزام بشروط الهدنه الانسانيه